hello everyone i'm abby shirt welcome to
abby's kitchen
today we're going to do things a little
bit differently because i've got some
construction going on at my house so we
are actually at the cottage this week
all week long i'm working from here and
actually it's canada day
while i'm shooting this i know you're
going to be watching this way later on
but i thought it was a good opportunity
while i was here to kind of bang some
vlog content before baby come so that
hopefully
i will have a little bit of time to kind
of prepare
and get things together and also you
never know when babies are gonna come
so i just want to kind of batch shoot as
much content as i possibly can
and of course that means shooting on a
stat holiday hashtag
entrepreneurship one of the really
popular formats on youtube
is responding to people's assumptions
about you
and i asked all of you on my youtube
community page what assumptions you had
or what other people had about me that
you've heard of
and that you wanted me to address so i
thought it'd be really fun some of them
are super mean but most of them are just
like really funny and also
interesting that those are things that
you might think about me there's also
like a lot of competing
um beliefs and assumptions so i thought
it would be really interesting to
address them
so i'm just going to settle in here to
my pseudo office with my
my coffee this is my favorite mug this
is the oivey mug
in the cottage i don't know if you guys
have like a
specific mug that you must consume your
coffee or tea out of like
no other mug in this whole cottage will
do other than the olive
i have to wash it between every single
time i want a drink because i only
will consume beverages in this so
this is what i'm gonna be having this
morning um and let's get to it
okay so the first assumption that you
all have about me and this is a really
popular one
was that you came from money now first
of all
it's absolutely true that i've never
struggled financially and of course that
is
such a privilege that i've been given
but i also wasn't born with a silver
spoon
in my mouth like some of you may think
um my parents both worked
incredibly hard throughout my childhood
and
my dad is still working my mom just
retired my mother
was a montessori teacher and actually
before that she was a ballet teacher but
anyways she was a montessori teacher and
worked her off
to eventually have the ability to open
up her own
school her own montessori school and run
that school which was an incredible
amount of work and i saw what she put
into that
my father growing up actually taught
photography at a community college
and he did that all day long that was
his day job that was how he was making
money
and then throughout the entire night he
would be studying and working
towards writing and getting his phd and
so now
he's a tenured professor but my sister
and i grew up in a very small
modest house outside of toronto we
couldn't of course afford to live
in the city in toronto um we never had a
family vacation
i think actually we had one family gate
vacation when i was 16.
my mother and father saved up for years
for that
because we just couldn't afford
vacations we ate very inexpensive simple
food nothing fancy nothing organic
we barely ever went out for meals but my
parents
taught both my sister and i had to work
incredibly hard for everything that we
want you know nothing was really handed
to us and both through my mother who was
an entrepreneur and my husband who's an
entrepreneur
i learned how to build my business
and of course i have a really supportive
family and a super supportive team who
helped me
kind of run this beast of a business but
it wasn't something that was just handed
to me i've honestly been working
my off for the past 10 years at this
um and i built it literally from nothing
so it's something that i'm
you know pretty proud of i'm proud of
that independence
assumption number two you're the mom who
gets mad when grandma gives
your kid sugar actually no
um my kid is like two and a half almost
actually when you're watching this could
be like two and a half
almost um and he regularly has sugar
i'm gonna do a whole video all about
this so that you guys see the whole
picture because i really can't explain
it in like one minute
um but i follow a method of feeding
called the division of responsibility
and part of this one of the
recommendations is to occasionally
allow unlimited access to sweets as a
snack
and also another really important tenet
is to never use
sweet foods as like a bribe to get your
child to eat something
healthy as a result my son has a pretty
balanced open relationship with food
i mean he is young but there are days
where he will choose to eat the broccoli
on his plate first
and there are other days when he will
choose to eat the pasta or the rice on
his plate first
and actually just the other day i
offered him a slice of the most amazing
key lime pie that i made and it was
sweet it was a
it was a sugar bomb but it was really
good and he literally ate
two bites and handed me the plate and
said i'm done
so i don't have rules about my kids not
having sugar
at home and i definitely don't have
rules about them not having sugar at
grandma and grandpa's house obviously
they're gonna have
sugar at grandma and grandma's house
that's part of the joy of being a
grandparent is
giving your your grandkids um an ice
cream cone
um but one of the little kind of rules i
do have is that i don't like to use the
word
treat even though my son still knows it
and i'm really just trying to not
reinforce it when he says it
um but i just want foods to be foods i
don't want them to hold moral weight i
don't want to be good or bad
i don't want to be yucky or yummy i want
a cake to be called a cake
and ice cream to be called an ice cream
and to put it to bed
so for me i'm way more concerned with
the long-term game
of raising a competent intuitive eater
rather than worrying about every single
little nutrient my child is getting in a
day again i'm going to do a whole video
all about this
if you guys are struggling with this
same issue or you could if you're
concerned about
your child eating too much sugar so
leave me a comment below and i will
definitely
get to that okay next you don't let your
kid
and your family eat fruit
okay so i think there's like this huge
misconception in the vegan community
that i am like
super against fruit and i think this
like dates back to this like
instagram post or one of many instagram
stories
i did of just like what my kid was
eating for a particular meal
when he was like seven months old um and
i mentioned
you know like i try to serve my child a
variety
of foods that was my goal and actually
my goal was
um when he started solids was to get to
100 different foods
by the time he was one and fruits were
easy right like he was always having a
lot of fruit at breakfast and at lunch
so it wasn't uncommon for me to not
serve it for dinner if he was already
having it for breakfast
lunch snacks etc also one thing to note
is that under one under the age of one
the iron needs are incredibly high and
iron rich foods for a lot of
toddlers and babies are a little bit
harder to tolerate fruit is easy
um you know so you don't want to crowd
out too many of those iron-rich
foods with just fruit all day
every single day um but now that my son
is
two like he's much older he's a very
competent eater this is not something
that i'm
ever concerned about he has multiple
servings of fruit
every single day as do i but under the
division of responsibility
if i'm offering at least one
safe food or fallback food at every
single meal
um and let's say my son has a temper
tantrum
and screams specifically for a peach if
it's not what i've decided to serve
in that meal i'm not going to give him a
peach what i'll probably say is
you know what we had a peach for lunch
and this is what we're having today and
i know you really like
avocado so we're going to have avocado
right now
and maybe we'll have a peach tomorrow
that would basically be my calm
response under the division of
responsibility but if i
offered a peach as part of that meal
then i will never
withhold the peach to get him to eat
something else on his plate
he can eat the peach whatever order he
wants in that meal
um you know i don't withhold food ever
however
i also don't let him run the show and
tell me that oh no mommy
i need a banana and a peach and a grapes
and and all of these things at one meal
no like there's not unlimited food in in
a normal household
period again i need to do a whole other
video on the divisional responsibility
to address
you know when there are unlimited
portions of particular foods and when of
course we need to
offer limited portions of them because
there is actual strict
evidence based guidelines around this
but anyways we are
huge fruit eaters in my household um i'm
always shocked at how much food we go
through every single week and
i mean it's just so expensive here in
canada as well um
but i i love fruit because there's so
many health benefits
both for myself and also for my growing
toddler
and i'm honestly way more concerned with
youtubers spreading misinformation that
fruit is
quote just sugar something that i have
never said period but there is a very
big difference
between promoting eating fruit out of
enjoyment
and out of the health properties versus
promoting eating
only fruit or huge proportions or
portions of fruit
while restricting or limiting other
really important macronutrients or foods
or food groups
like fat so when you hear me making
commentary about someone else's
excessive fruit intake
it's not from a place of fruit hating
it's simply at a concern that there may
be some
demonizing or restricting of other
really important
foods in the diet we don't want any one
food to crowd out
everything else here's the thing while
it may seem like nitpicking
i am actually trying to use all of the
meals that i review
to teach the public at large a little
bit about
balance one single meal will not make or
break your health
at all um whether that's eating a lot of
fruit or eating a lot of chips it
doesn't really matter
it's about the pattern it also doesn't
really give us an accurate
representation
of that particular person's relationship
with food but my videos would have no
teachable moments if i just said
fruit is healthy great end of story next
i mean
of course fruit is healthy but
ultimately my goal with these diet
reviews is to provide some
useful suggestions on how to optimize
your meals and snacks
by just thinking about variety and
balance including
how to balance fruit intake with other
nutritious
foods and the story okay next assumption
is that you are a perfectionist
and type a personality what gave you
guys that
idea um yes
my perfectionism has been both a
blessing and a curse in my life
it has definitely driven me to build a
really successful business
and be great at what i do but it has
also caused
so many health issues from you know
disordered eating
anxiety insomnia probably played a role
in my infertility etc
would i ever trade my personality in no
this this is what makes me who i am so
of course not
but it has just meant that i've had to
work a lot harder
um to find happiness and peace just
doing everyday things like working and
parenting next assumption
you are the responsible parent i would
say so
um not maybe the responsible one but i'm
definitely like the bad cop
um and you know sometimes my toddler i'm
not the favorite
that and that that's okay um but you
know my husband is an amazing father he
also does not put up with crap and
tantrums and things like that we're
definitely on the same page on those
kinds of things
but he's just got like way more energy
to be fun and silly and like
any little tiny boy is going to love
that
so yeah he wins okay so the next one was
that you binge watched
tidying up with marie kondo and there's
a lot of assumptions about me being like
a clean freak or whatever i guess it
like comes with the type
type a perfectionist personality or
whatever
the truth is i am very organized
um and i get that from my mother who you
know has
she's the queen of excel spreadsheets
she has like a label maker that she uses
like
to label every single box or or drawer
or or folder or whatever and to-do lists
my yoga they make me calm i just like
put everything on that straighten my
hair
yes have breakfast yes i love to
check things off of my to-do list so i
am organized in mind
but i'm not necessarily tidy and as my
husband would say
if he left me in the house by myself for
a whole weekend
he would come back to an absolute pigsty
i am admittedly pretty messy i didn't
grow up in a like meticulous home like
my husband did
so you know we kind of fight over this
sometimes because my
my standards are like a little bit lower
i don't like unsanitary spaces like
that's gross big no for me i hate
stacks of papers like one of my favorite
things i love throwing out stacks of
papers i love throwing out
old birthday cards or christmas cards or
whatever i'm not a hoarder
so i guess the murray condo thing a
little bit but yes i'm messy
i leave my clothes on the floor i don't
make my bed
don't care about it um i don't put my
shoes
tightly together i just like kick them
off when i come in the door i just
oh and i leave the cupboards open in the
kitchen all the time that's a big
big bone of contention in my house but i
just have other priorities
oh and look at my desktop tabs
like i can't close them if somebody were
to close them i would freak
out so yeah there's a method to my
madness but
i'm not i'm not a tidy freak i am an
organized freak
okay so next is that you are miss
perfect
and have never struggled with any health
or hormonal
issues gosh no um and i think i've been
really candid on my channel and my blog
about some of my health struggles i
haven't hid
anything but you know in childhood i've
struggled with anxiety since i was a
little
child and it's had major impacts on my
health and my mental health
physical emotional etc i was bullied a
lot
in high school and childhood um in in
my teen years i had an eating disorder i
was diagnosed with pcos
after i got married and as a result i
went through years of infertility and
ivf
and um three miscarriages trying to
build my family
but having said all of that any time i
do think about or talk about these
things
i always acknowledge that i am so
blessed
and so privileged for the position that
i'm in you know
i have a really supportive family and
partner throughout this
all of these issues and and i have been
able to see a therapist
when i want to and i have been able to
afford ivf and i've been
young enough and healthy enough that
it's worked like like
i want no sympathy i acknowledge every
day that i am one of the
lucky ones and i'm so appreciative
of the resources that i've had okay
next is this is a fun one trying to
lighten the mood here
you take baths not showers
so yes of course i occasionally have to
take showers to wash my hair
but if i'm going to get 20 minutes of
uninterrupted
me time i want to be off my feet i mean
you know i'm on my feet all day long i
want to just like lay in the hot water
maybe shave my legs probably not
especially now because i literally
cannot see anything
below my belly but you know
i've probably been on my feet all day
and so the last thing i want to have to
do
is stay on them okay next one is that
you were the bully or the high school
bully or the regina george of your high
school
this one is so wrong um i was actually
an art student
in a school that had a particular arts
program and we used to get made fun of
all the time by all of the non-arts
students and also by like the science
teachers as well which is ironic because
now i'm in a science
field um but i was actually bullied a
lot in high school and
as a child because you know i was kind
of naive i was lanky i was never the
prettiest or the coolest
of my friends like for example while
some of my friends
in you know when in middle school or
whatever were into boys
i was still building like acorn
gardens to attract fairies i was a geek
needless to say also at a really young
age i was doing a lot of traveling
um and auditioning for tv and traveling
for for singing and songwriting with
different producers in new york and
london
so i just couldn't really always relate
to a lot of the kids in my cohort
also in my last year of high school i
stood up to
the actual regina george of our high
school because she was bullying a friend
of mine
and all of her friends who were also my
friends at the time were
so scared of kind of calling her out
about anything probably because they
were
scared of her making their life hell as
well
and when i did they turned on me so
i spent the second half of my graduating
year in high school with half of my
friends
not even talking to me and funny enough
they still don't talk to me
so yeah as a small town small town drama
is so strange
and bizarre and i am just so glad to be
past that i'm dreading the high school
years as a parent
okay next question is that you never eat
fast food
i don't never eat fast food in fact i
ate it all the time when i was
a teenager in high school and i was
living in like a suburb
but now i live downtown toronto
surrounded by
all of like the country's best
restaurants so
i would just way rather support a local
business
than like a massive burger chain so in
non-cova times
we would probably like uber eats in at
least like a lunch or dinner
something maybe a couple times a week if
we were
if i was really tired from cooking all
day at work um and then maybe go out for
dinner
once a week or once every other week
somewhere really great and
and eat like 2 000 calories an amazing
local food
and call it a day so it's not that i
avoid fast food because it's unhealthy
absolutely not it's just that if i'm
going to spend my money
on food outside the home that i didn't
prepare i just feel like
i've got so many delicious options
living in the city
but i also do eat chips and ice cream
and i'd like a stash of chocolate in my
cupboard in my pantry and i love candied
nuts that's one of my favorites
don't love pop because it like really
makes my teeth hurt and i've got really
sensitive teeth so i'm a baby at that
but i definitely have a sweet tooth and
i do not
ever deny myself that okay next question
is you care a lot about not being fat
and very much want to stay thin
okay so here's what i have to say about
this because no one i mean
at least very few people would choose a
life that is inherently
harder for them and there is no question
that being slim affords me a lot of
privileges
that being fat would not so sure it is
nice that my body is naturally
smaller of course that is a privilege
that i enjoy because our society
praises smaller bodies and shames larger
bodies
but i'm not a place in my life where my
priorities have really changed
and i'm just not willing to put myself
through a punishing
diet or exercise regime or you know
even just jeopardize the work that i've
done on my relationship with food in my
body
simply to shrink my body in the
situation if and when it does get bigger
and it is and it's going to continue to
get bigger as i
get older of course and i'll just have
to continue to do that work
to find peace and health and happiness
even in a larger body i'm not saying
that this is going to be easy because
society makes it such an uphill battle
for for people especially women um with
their relationship with food and their
bodies
but i do think it is a challenge that is
worth
embarking on next you have thrown
serious shade while filming and i've had
to edit it out
okay so i'm definitely really mindful
about my followers sensitivities and
i never want to purposefully offend
anyone
even when i'm reviewing a youtuber who i
just
really disagree with of course i get
emotional sometimes because i'm
passionate about what i do and i get
upset and
occasionally i like have to wash
something back and i think oh maybe i
should adjust
the delivery on that um but i will say
that
that doesn't really actually happen that
much anymore because i think i've just
become
more sensitive and mature and
professional
in my delivery over time next is you
never eat
packaged foods and you always prefer to
like make yourself a fruit bowl
so you have more control over what you
eat
um definitely not i get sent a lot of
like really great snack foods and bars
from brands
every single week so i'm always trying
new bars and snacks and pre-packaged
foods
out and i'd say like unlike a lot of
youtubers who are a lot younger
and single and have a little bit more
time
i just don't have the bandwidth to make
everything from scratch
anymore i just don't um and there are
just so many great
packaged options nowadays that i
definitely like to have on hand to kind
of munch on between meals
so if you guys want to see like a snack
haul um like a pantry haul you can see
like all the different random snacks
that i have
bars and things in my pantry leave me a
comment below i think that'd make a
really fun video
okay next is you curse a lot when you're
not in front of the camera
how did you know um yes i uh
now actually a lot less now than i was
even just like a year ago because my son
is in this phase where he literally
repeats back everything it's dangerous
it is a dangerous
phase so i've had to become a little bit
more careful about
what i say and where i say it but
considering
nobody's around right now i do still
like
to say okay next one is really funny
you only wear one-piece swimsuits with
the little skirt
attached and i'm laughing because like i
don't know how you guys know this like
have you been in my underwear drawer
but seriously up until like maybe a
couple of months ago
that was like all i had i had tons of
one pieces
that's not true like i have a lot of of
two pieces too but i did
love like the kind of 1950s style that
has like
the little like ruffle at the bottom but
i will
say like i actually tried to like dig
them out when i read this because i was
like that is so funny
um and i think i gave them away when i
did my well i didn't give them away like
i
i took them to the donation bin when i
did like a big
big purge i guess you guys were right
about the the marie condo i did do
a marie kondo purge like i don't know
several months ago but before that video
even came out but anyways
i did get rid of a bunch of those those
bathing suits because they're just not
my style and honestly
i couldn't even fit into any one piece
right now because
look at this what
i don't know unless it was an eternity
one
that would not get very far so it's
it's uh bikinis string bikinis are the
only option
in this state right now okay next is you
have toned down your personality in
order to have
more widespread appeal i don't know
if it's about widespread appeal but of
course i have toned down my personality
a little bit like i was looking at
old videos of myself like some of my old
recipe videos and i was thinking
ugh i used to have so much fun and i was
so funny
what happened but but honestly i think
it's like just a really a maturity thing
i think i've just grown as a person and
a professional
and while i may kind of like have
immediate thoughts in my head
i'm just a lot more calculated in how i
communicate them
but you can usually tell what i'm
actually thinking in that second
just by watching my facial expressions
when i'm watching like a wedding in a
day video or something like that so take
a look at that you might enjoy
you might enjoy doing some some kind of
deep dive interpretations of my
inner thoughts but yeah i definitely am
way funnier offline in real life
but um you know everything on youtube
gets teased apart and criticized so i
have
learned to consider every possible
interpretation
next you kind of like when people that
you made a video about respond
no i hate it i'm not here to stir you
know
my you know oh my gosh canada
i have a goal and my goal is to call out
problematic and supportive wellness
information here on youtube and in
social media
so when somebody gets angry and attacks
me because my
professional views don't align with
whatever they're selling
um and they come at me and attack me
personally or my parenting etc
you know i don't even watch like come at
me with science let's have a science
battle that is more my style
um but like people who want to attack me
personally
i have no time for that okay next is a
big one um
it is that you're an optimist when it
comes to intuitive eating
and you believe that the obesity
epidemic is propaganda
okay so lots to unpack here but very
quickly
as quickly and succinctly as i can
intuitive eating is often misconstrued
as
eat whatever junk you want diet it's not
intuitive eating also takes into
consideration nutrition
and also gathering information about how
certain foods
make you feel emotionally and physically
and it's also about knowing that if you
decide to eat a food that is
not going to make you feel very good or
serve your health that it doesn't
trigger this guilt response that spirals
you
into restriction and binging and no the
obesity epidemic is not propaganda
obesity can be a real huge health
problem
there's no question but i am just
way more inclined to call out
problematic unhealthy behaviors
rather than the specific look of
somebody's body because
ultimately we cannot judge someone's
health
by just looking at their body as for
haze
i'm actually pretty moderate in where i
stand in the haze versus weight loss
dietetics community in fact a lot of
hayes dietitians
don't like me because i think that
there's room for both of those
possibilities and
and for me it's really more about being
client centered
and meeting the client of the patient
where they are
while also maximizing health and
minimizing
risk i have a lot more information about
where i stand
in this whole argument in this video
right here so you can definitely
check that out okay another really quick
one you are an enigram
type x y and z so i got a lot of guesses
about this whole enigram personality
type
and which one that i was there was lots
of different options and guesses
and i had no idea what the heck it meant
so i looked it up
and i would say i'm probably an a type
one or three or both i don't know which
is the perfectionist
and the performer which i think makes
sense because they also are kind of
related anyway anyways leave me a
comment below if you guys want to
kind of rebut me on that and tell me
what personality type i
am okay next is you're gonna be the
class mom queen
this is my dream this was my dream
before i became a parent
um i always wanted to be that house on
the block that had like a full haunted
house at halloween
and gave it like full-size chocolate
bars and candy apples and like
had like people dressed up that came out
of came behind trees and out of the
garage and things like that
and i wanted to like build a lemonade
stand for my son and sell like gourmet
smoothies and fresh
fresh pressed juices and homemade snacks
and like make the most badass beautiful
cupcakes and desserts for like the
school bake sale
like these are my big aspirations of
motherhood
but the reality is um i can't even get
my act together to like
buy candy for halloween until like that
afternoon so yeah and obviously we
haven't gone to the bake sale thing yet
but
i just can imagine myself just being so
frazzled being like
i know i should do this but i have
absolutely
no time so we'll see that's my dream
but we'll see if it becomes a reality
okay so this assumption is actually like
the opposite of the last one and it's
really funny it's
it's that i'm actually a bit of a hot
mess mom and
i would say yeah i try really hard not
to be but
you know i think everyone thinks that
i'm like miss perfect and all put
together but
i honestly feel like i'm failing at most
things
most of the time like my husband on the
other hand
much better parent than i am way better
he's amazing
he's also way better at like balancing
work and
and and parenthood or home life than i
am and not letting stress
get to him i always show up i
always get it done and i always do a
pretty damn good job
but i also think it's often at the
expense of like my mental health
and uh and i often just feel like i'm
just
staying above water okay next is that
you secretly
judge people at the grocery store no
oh never i mean when i had orthorexia
yes all the time it was terrible and i
remember
i still have this memory of being in
like maybe my early twenties
um late teens even and like judging this
mom who had formula on the conveyor belt
because i had like being taught breast
is best breast is best
and as a mom who now had such a struggle
breastfeeding
i feel sick to my stomach that i even
had that thought for even a moment
honestly i have not judged a single item
in a person's
food cart ever i'm sure that if people
knew i was a dietitian they'd be judging
me hard
um but yeah the only thoughts that i've
ever had about what someone's putting on
the conveyor belt is if like
they are having a party and i'm jealous
that i'm not invited because they have
like all my favorite snacks and pop and
things like that
but that is literally the only thoughts
that i have about somebody's grocery
haul
okay next is that i wore braces and
watched a lot of degrassi growing up um
yes and no um but basically was never
really a degrassi fan
i have to be totally honest i was more
of like a sweet valley high girl does
anybody remember that show
so good so good why don't we have
television like that for kids anymore
but anyways i did have braces i had
braces to
fix what i call the madonna gap i had
like a gap between a two front teeth
hopefully my teeth are clean now it's i
got really straight teeth of course
because i'm anal about wearing my
retainer i still wear my retainers
like 20 years later basically not 20 but
you know
i don't even know how old i am 15 years
later um
but now like i feel like that gap is in
and i love madonna so i kind of
i kind of miss and regret kind of
getting rid of that characteristic
feature next is you are very into quinoa
okay dietitian confession here folks
i don't love quinoa i don't love quinoa
i actually don't love most grains like
i eat them but i don't love them i don't
really like couscous and i don't like
rice
very much um and i don't love quinoa
i cook with it and i make recipes with
it but i don't love it i would
way rather have like pasta or bread or
sweet potatoes
or fruit as my carb of choice so that
one is a big
for me next is that you wear sunscreen
all of the time
probably spf 60.
nailed it what do you mean i'm pale
but yes look at all these look at all
these moles and freckles my son
calls all my moles and freckles boo-boos
so i have like a ton
of boo-boos apparently um and i've had
lots of like problematic moles and
things like that removed in my life so
yes i
slather that stuff on even in the dead
of winter okay next is
you have limitless energy and you don't
know where it came from
definitely and like my husband who's
been with me for like 12 years or
something still
is amazed with the amount of energy that
i have
but i will say it is totally just dying
here at the end of this pregnancy
and honestly it makes me feel really
depressed
and kind of guilty like i hate not being
able to do
what i think i should be able to do but
honestly it's nothing that like i eat
the energy doesn't come from what i eat
or drink or do
i think it's just from my internal drive
to do
things really really well so yeah
see my response on perfectionism 101
okay next is that you think every form
of restriction is unhealthy because of
your orthorexic
past not necessarily i think this is a
highly individual thing and also you
know really comes down to intention
if you're restricting something even
though that something
feels really good to you physically and
emotionally
then yeah i would say that may be
unhealthy and is very likely to lead to
a cycle
of binging and restriction or just a
general distrust with food but if you're
restricting something for
religious reasons moral reasons or
health reasons
meaning that consuming that thing or
that food
would not support your health your
mental well-being your physical
well-being etc
then no i think that that could be a
really healthy thing to
do like i said it's super personalized
and individualized
okay a fun one you're a gemini and your
favorite
ice cream flavor is mint chocolate chip
okay
not a gemini i'm actually a sagittarius
and i like mint chocolate chip i loved
it as a child
but i will say my favorite ice cream
flavor and i eat a lot of ice cream is
anything with like salted caramel or
caramel flavors pralines and creams
caramel cups
anything like that i'm actually not a
huge chocolate person
period i would probably rather have no
ice cream than just
plain chocolate ice cream don't shoot me
okay next is you work your ass off and
you have a very hard
time giving yourself a break case in
point today canada day stat holiday here
i am
working um yes i do and i honestly have
a lot of
a lot of guilt about it because i often
feel like it's take it takes away from
my family like it is
right now um but i'm doing this because
i'm trying to
get ahead so that i can spend more time
with my family when this baby comes and
have a little bit of
sanity but anyways you know this for me
just runs in the family my father is
like a bona fide
workaholic my mother worked also
incredibly hard to build her business
while also taking care of us um and you
know my dad like he's retirement age
not retiring he still works all day all
night all weekends
even on sabbatical it's it's insane and
my
sister who's a phd psychologist and i
we both know that we kind of have that
gene but we both feel like we need to
like actively work
to try to find better work-life balance
i'm working on it i got a lot of work to
do okay
another big controversial one you are
obsessed with
protein i can see why people think this
and it's probably because
i review more high carb vegans
than any other type of youtubers when it
comes to diet and
and that's because that's who you
recommend or or request
most often but i am trying to actively
change that so
hopefully you won't be seeing too much
of that but anyways
in those situations of course i don't
need to be
telling that person or we're talking
about the need to include
more carbs in the diet it's usually the
recommendation that i'm giving
is that we want to balance those carbs
out with other macronutrients like
protein
and like fat carbs are very important
and i also do try to call out when
they're being unnecessarily
demonized or when protein portions get
like super excessive like 50 grams plus
with nothing else but when i surveyed my
colleagues on this
um they often told me that they're way
more concerned with their clients
getting enough protein than getting
enough carbs so as a result
they often recommend a higher fiber
moderately higher protein diet to most
of their general
healthy clients the reason for this is
that protein is just more inherently
satiating than high gi carbs which can
be really helpful and important for
helping to maintain stable energy levels
managing appetite and also maintaining
metabolic muscle mass
it's not about cutting out carbs and i'm
also not into
you know massive low carb super high
protein portions of just like chicken
breasts
and egg whites but i just am aware of
the research that shows that
most people feel better when they pair
their carbohydrate
with a source of protein or fat or both
so avoiding those naked carbs or at
least
choosing higher fiber lower gi carbs
more often
you married your high school sweetheart
kindergarten actually
um my husband and i were friends when we
were six
and we started dating when i was 19.
okay you were at the top of your class
in undergrad
yes um i actually graduated with the top
gpa in our school i was the class
president i won all the top scholarships
and awards
and honestly it wasn't because i'm
inherently smarter
it was just because i literally worked
myself
to the bone and i honestly i totally
regret the emotional strain that it put
on me because
the difference between a 4.33 and a 4.0
in the grand scheme of your career and
your life
probably wasn't worth the emotional toll
that it had on me
okay you have a love-hate relationship
with social media and your job
yes oh my gosh it is a daily battle and
there are so many days where i think to
myself
why am i putting myself through this
hell it's brutal
um and i wonder if i should continue on
right but there are so many of you who
send me
these beautiful messages every single
day i get
dozens and hundreds of them telling me
how much i've helped you
in your journey with intuitive eating or
helped you change your relationship with
food or helped you recover from your
disordered eating
and that makes all the drama worth it
but yes i honestly effing hate social
media i think it's so contrived
it's so fake and i'm so jealous of like
my husband who doesn't use it or my
friends who just use it to post photos
of their cats
or like their ice cream cone for fun
next is you like to be in control
yes um see my answer on perfectionism
and type a personalities but
yes i do like to have control um and
uh and i do all the planning in my
friend group and my family
and i'm also an entrepreneur so of
course i call the shots in that world
as well and i'm admittedly not very
spontaneous like
i like to have things planned out and i
think it's because
i want to avoid disappointment when i
built something up in my head
i don't want to just like have a bad
experience that to me is like
so sad so for example on the weekends
like pre-covet at least i would like
pack our weekends
full of activities and outings and
play dates and things like that because
i didn't want to have to get to another
beginning of the work week and feel like
i regretted that i didn't
milk my beautiful weekend i don't know
does anyone else feel like that
raise your hand raise your hand show me
some support i don't want to be the only
one
also if i'm on a holiday i will probably
plan out
most of the meals for the entire trip
whereas like my husband would just be
happy to walk in a place
but i don't want to go home from my
holiday something that i don't get to do
very often or maybe ever again and feel
like i'm regretting that i didn't
check out that one awesome restaurant
that
people on the internet were talking
about after the fact now i will say i
have become
more flexible in like the day-to-day
things so in the restaurant example like
i never really plan what i'm going to
eat
when i go to a restaurant i want to sit
down and just see what i feel like in
that moment
but you know generally speaking yes i do
like to plan
okay the next funny one is that you are
a karen
who wrote that i hate karen's honestly i
actively cringe when i'm out for dinner
and someone goes all karen on the wait
staff it's like
i'm not with them but anyways i think
it's because like i've worked in the
service industry in hospitality industry
so i've got a little bit more empathy
and i'm just more understanding
when it hits the fan then maybe some
other people
might be but no i am not a karen and i
hope that anyone that goes out with me
in real life
would not think that i'm a karen i'm
going to actively be auntie karen
from now on oh here is another little
juicy nugget
you work for the meat and dairy industry
i don't work for meat and dairy
i i'm an entrepreneur so i work for
myself
but i do have the opportunity to partner
with brands and commodity boards
that i trust and that i believe in to
create content
and create really awesome recipes and i
have the flexibility to work with both
plant-based
brands and non-plant-based brands
because
i myself do not have any major dietary
restrictions
i also acknowledge that the vast
majority of my followers are not vegan
and do consume or feed their families
some meat or dairy products
um so yeah for me it's all about meeting
people where they are and creating just
good content period i would never work
with a brand that i
felt didn't serve my family or didn't
serve some subsect
of my audience's family so i really kind
of only work about 25
of brands that reach out to me so i'm
really actually
very very selective but if i post a
recipe that has nuts in it for example
and you have a nut allergy
then that content isn't for you and i've
got lots of other nut-free recipes that
will be
and if i post a recipe with chicken in
it and you're vegan then that recipe is
not for you
but i've got lots of great vegetarian
and vegan recipes that
are i think we can all respect that the
majority of north americans
do consume some animal products still in
their family
and that i can continue to promote
eating more plant-based
while still acknowledging that there may
be some room for some animal products if
that is what your family enjoys
i believe that even just reducing animal
products in the diet is helpful
and also is just more realistic for a
lot of people who
are just not ready to make that leap to
full-blown veganism
okay you have never successfully held a
nine-to-five job and that is why
you blog so i have had nine-to-five jobs
but i've hated them
and that's why i'm not doing that right
now i i love what i do
that was never my plan my plan was never
to
have a nine-to-five job i was either
going to
go into academics and probably teach or
i was going to use my
media training and my tv experience and
teach on a much more math scale which is
basically what i'm doing right now
also i was totally born to be my own
boss
because as we've already established i
like to be in control
so yeah entrepreneurship just spoke to
me okay
next is that you are extremely impatient
and want results
in every aspect of your life immediately
nailed it honestly yes i'm probably one
of the most impatient people
you will ever meet i take like 10 minute
showers not because necessarily i don't
have
the time to take anything longer but
because i just cannot wait
to get to the next important task
whereas there are other people in my
family who
you know we could be late and they could
be taking a leisurely shower
and brushing and flossing their each
individual tooth perfectly and
whistling well i am losing my mind
pulling my hair out just trying to get
out
of the house but yeah for example when i
wanted a baby
i wanted it now and infertility was one
of the most
heartbreaking and frustrating
experiences of my life
because i just felt like there was
always something slowing me down on my
path
also my husband always jokes that um
when i want something or when i want to
get somewhere i would like
mow down a bunch of old ladies just to
get there because they would be
slowing me down and in my way so yeah
i'm pretty impatient and the last
question here is
you're a horse girl growing up
[Laughter]
honestly i told my husband um that this
was one of the assumptions and he was
like i would divorce you
um but no he grew up on a farm and had
horses
and definitely just is not a horse girl
kind of guy but in all honesty i went to
horse camp when i was a kid because
that's what my friends wanted to do and
that was like the fun thing to do
um and i liked horses i mean what child
doesn't like horses unless of course
they're scared of them and they had
something traumatic happen to them
but yeah it definitely wasn't my passion
growing up i was doing a lot more
singing and dancing and acting and
things like that but
yeah i enjoy i enjoy a horse i do enjoy
a horse
well that was fun i had fun doing this
and i hope that cleared a few things up
for you guys
if you enjoyed this video of course give
the thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
turn on that little bell so you don't
miss a a video
um and if you have other crazy
assumptions that you might have about me
or maybe you've
heard about me or whatever leave me a
comment below i'm happy to address them
in another video this was really
kind of fun to do and yeah i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you